the White House says President Trump
plans to visit Pittsburgh soon though
his schedule is already packed with a
number of campaign rallies all across
the country he did order flags at
federal buildings to fly at half-staff
until Wednesday in honor of the victims
the president also mixed condemnation of
the killings with verbal attacks on his
critics
wooja Jang is at the White House we
should good morning president Trump
spent the weekend trying to deal with a
country in mourning
while still trying to gain momentum
ahead of the midterm elections the
president said he considered cancelling
his rally on Saturday but would not let
evil win then he joked he could have
bailed because of his quote bad hair day
after answering reporters questions
about the shooting in the rain the
president condemned anti-semitism though
his stance on gun control did not sway
claiming the shooter would have been
stopped if an armed guard was posted
inside the synagogue critics including
billionaire Democratic donor Tom Styer a
target of last week's Mayo bomb scare
accused mr. Trump of creating an
atmosphere of political violence steyr
is behind a flurry of anti Trump
advertisements the president after
watching steyr on CNN wrote he comes off
as a crazed and stumbling lunatic steyr
fired back criticizing the president for
name-calling during this tragic time of
course it will be interesting to see if
the president's tone continues to waver
with just over a week before Election
Day he has so many rallies planned this
week across the country in trump's
friendly states gale we should thank you